Oh, do you guys have an exciting taxi journey? Yeah, so I,
I convinced Joey to get a taxi cause Jerry wanted to get the train home.
Cause it's about like half the price, but you know, he was like.
It was the day where Connor and I was streaming at the trash day's office.
If you guys saw.
Yeah. But it was like 11:00 PM when we finished. Yeah. And I was like,
getting the train home, come on, Joe. Let's get taxi on. Let's be comfortable.
Let's you know, it's late.
What you see?
I don't know why you like have this massive thing about like the comfort in
taxi. It's not that much, not comfortable, much more comfortable.
You see it as if it's like business class versus economy. Honestly.
The way I see it,
like also right now with the Rohner going on out of re if I can avoid getting a
train, I'll avoid it. Yeah.
I, I understand that. But for me,
like I would most like 90% of the time I would rather get like, have,
have a longer journey that I can actually do stuff on because I can't do
anything on a taxi. I look, I can do more on attacks.
I look at my phone and I immediately just get on a train in Japan. I mean,
you can watch YouTube videos
because I get car sick because I didn't know why.
I'm sorry that your natural selection didn't favor your charity. My problem
[inaudible] I think most people get car sick stuff.
I'm focusing on the YouTube video. Yeah.
It's because it's because you can't see outside. So the inertia just you up.
Yeah. Because that's how you get,
and I'm not sure about the exact science of car sickness,
but I've liked cars are the only vehicle. I get motion sickness in.
Anything else I can like read? I can.
Lift boats.
That's not carsick vehicle. I don't think I get seasick. Really?
I get C6. I get, I guess,
slightly seasonal because normally people who are car sick as sea sick.
I don't get carsick that easily though. Unless you're watching something.
But if I'm looking down at my phone or like, I can't like, like, I,
I don't get car sick if I'm just sitting there listening to music.
Hell then yeah. It's boring. When you have to shovel like four hours in a car,
what do you call? And I can go to bed. Yeah.
That's why I think that's why I've conditioned myself to be able to sleep so
easily in cars because I literally can't do anything in cars, sleep.
And listen to me.
I can do the exact same thing on a bus and not get sick on a bus.
I could be on a bus and watch YouTube or whatever or read. I can look at the,
you don't want to do this, but I can't. But, but,
but if I did it in the car, I think it's five minutes in.
I think it's the smaller the vehicle. The more likely to get sick.
I don't know what the science is behind that. But if it's like a, like,
if it's like a small taxi,
especially if it's a small taxi and we're like squeezed in then the back seat.
And if you're in the backseat, I just get immediately.
You're the son of the taxi. I don't want to,
I don't want to make eye contact with the taxi.
You don't have to. What do you think?
You're just going to do this the entire sometimes, you know,
you might find yourself wandering and you're like.
Wait a minute. This is awkward moment of like, hi, I did no,
I never drive in good driving.
I'm awkward. I don't want to make eye contact. Like I have the,
I have the same problem in the back seat where I accidentally sometimes look at
[inaudible] eyes with them. And then just like,
hi that you just have to do my back silent. Like the worst, the worst.
When there are awful drivers. Well,
you got to pretend like they're doing a good job and they're just sad.
I mean the front,
cause I'm less likely to get sick in the front from driving down in the back.
Cause you're thrown around in the back. Anyway. The stories. Yeah,
we were talking about, I can go back into tax anyway.
So Connor was like, look, it's it's 20 minutes home on a,
on a comfy taxi quicker by only like five, 10 minutes.
Closer to our house. Cause we don't have to go to the station. We'll walk right.
Not that much, but yeah.
So I was like, all right, it. I'll humor your taxi ride.
So then we get in the taxi, the taxi is driving fine.
And then we go onto this slight kind of breech thing. And uh,
and then it's just some random police officer just walks out onto the street and
kind of flags us down. Right. And tells us to go into one of the roads.
And immediately the taxi driver was like, does the Japanese equivalent of, Oh.
He's like slate as nine-year-old. Oh.
And he pulls in and Conrad, like what the is going on?
And I asked the taxi driver, I'm like, uh, something wrong. And he's like,
I was speeding. I was like, well,
you got stopped for speeding. And he's like, yeah, I was doing 80 down to 60.
And this old dude just like walks out of the taxi, like, you know,
Ozzy Osborne started just like kind of stumbles out.
Four policemen surrounded this old poor old man.
Yeah. And like in the middle of the night is he's filling out this paperwork and
Connor. And I was just kind of sitting there being like, Oh,
we could have been home by now. If we went on the train one time,
a human this man to get on the taxi.
First time I ever had a taxi driver been pulled over by the police, you know,
because I was like, I was like, I was just hoping that they wouldn't be like,
all right, let's have a look. What these,
these boys in the back look pretty foreign.
Let's see what's going on with these boys.
Come on. Yeah. No, I was afraid that might happen as well.
So immediately like before the police officer even started talking to us,
I just immediately he'd be like, what's going on? Yes. I am. Japanese.
Officers asked us. They were like, is it okay if we stop you for now?
Like the driver? Yeah.
W w w w w what if we said, no,
we're in the middle of nowhere. There's no taxis anywhere.
What do you expect us to do? Like.
Pulled us over there over some bridge. So there wasn't like much there.
So it was just like some water. Right.
And like a bunch of like a power plant nearby. So I was like, no, thanks.
I was pretty honest.
For police officers. Like busted down this decrepit town.
Yeah. Just for this guy.
Then there's two other police officers just standing there doing nothing because
that's what they do here.
Every police officer, every police story I've heard in Japan is,
is all about how many police officers you need versus how many was that?
I actually need to be sent like six police officers to like, you know,
someone falling over on a bike. Yeah. It's like, it's insane.
There's so bored here. They've nothing to do old. They need.
Spotters. Right. I got you, bro. Nice policing. You're doing that.
Yeah. Cause normally.
Okay. It's always like two people. Like it's always just a squad. Yeah, exactly.
You don't want on your apartment. Right. That's normally how it should be.
Right. Because also this, I don't know if this is on purpose,
but it's very intimidating when four or five policemen are crowding around you
and you haven't done anything and they're asking you questions. They all,
they all look off and I'm like, well, come on, let's go on here. Then.
[Inaudible] bad for the old dude.
Cause he looked like he was about to get beaten up by school police officers
because they literally just, just crowding around him.
Just like looking down at the people.
I've never been in this situation as well.
So this is the first time where I've been near police where they haven't asked
for like my ID and like information stuff.
Yeah. Because I busted out the Japanese crew.
Cause you just go near them and they're like, Hey, can we see ID and all this?
And I'm like, why I'm not involved in this? I'm literally just a customer.
Leave me alone.
Do you think I had a gun pointing to this?
[inaudible] like stop playing European in the background. Hey, come on gas,
drift this corner. I know I'm doing it. I'm not, I'm doing it all the time.